[Music]
why then has the ultimate multiverse
gained in popularity and why now do you
reckon why do I think it's game yeah
it's not just scientific is it no it's
not just scientific um and of course so
again sorry I forgive the historical
move that I always want to do but um
that the first real sort of respectable
vision of the multiverse in physics came
out of the many-worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics in the 1950s and then
in the 1980s entre Linda Alex Vilenkin
started positing eternal and chaotic
inflation right so these ideas were
around but we the multiverse starts
exploding around the turn of the
millennium I mean suddenly it's on
bookstores it's in it's and it's
whatever the bookstores are now it's you
know the early internet it's absolutely
everybody talking about the multiverse I
think within physics
it seems that part of we do I think have
to talk about the entropic principle I
think part of the impetus came from the
discovery of dark energy in 1998 and the
intensification of the perceived
fine-tuning problem the idea that it
seems like the universe is so perfectly
calibrated that if if gravity were any
different if ever any stronger maybe the
universe would collapse into a Big
Crunch or if the cosmological constant
were any stronger it would blow apart
how is it possible that everything is
just right that we can get galaxies and
planets and stars and Donovan and
whatever else that we get and so so
Steven Weinberg begins to say in 2000
2001 look I think that this fine-tuning
problem is going to force the idea of
the multiverse on and suddenly Alex
blinken's phone is ringing and Andrei
Linde s phone is ringing and you know
they're like ringing up Hugh Everett
from the dead and being like sorry dudes
maybe your idea was right right because
we have this intensified fine-tuning
problem which again from my perspective
the problem is that it keeps nudging
physics closer to theologians who are
like ah we have a fine-tuned universe we
got an answer for that
it's our dude it's our guy we've been
talking about this oh go make sure this
is right well it's either that or an
infinity of universes alright that's it
that's your choice and this is what this
is this is if you don't want God you'd
better have a multiverse
right so I think that's gold I think
that it's not obvious but I think they
claim I think that you're mentioning
emergent I think is it's a PI group
enough to make it as general sickness
not quite valid and what he was
referring to is the point that I have
been making in the past few years is
that that idea may not be correct so but
that does not talk about the generalized
general framework not being correct it's
just the way people are not using it may
be incorrect so I think the idea that
the de fine-tuning problems in physics
whether or not they are anthropometry
simple or they are related to deeper
principles we have to learn we have to
study down on the Sun people that put
forth the idea that some aspects may be
related to aspects that we exist and
therefore yet there we won't we won't be
existing on outer space we exist on
planets that's not a crazy idea you know
there's gravity you get stuck there and
so so that could be a similar to some
aspects not everything and if everything
is trying to be explained then all the
fine tunings based on war exists and
sounds that it is strange many people in
life you don't like that I don't think I
am I would I would myself not like it I
would find that's a last resort to go in
that direction but most people are
people are looking for alternatives
including myself I've written papers
that he's referring to trying to advance
other alternatives to that question but
is it do you from your point of view was
the the increase in an interest in the
multiverse forced on you or as a result
of trying to deal with the fine tunings
so so so it was kind of relation before
Weinberg's and before the measuring of
the dark energy the fact that there are
infinitely many solutions and string
theory was known that was not that was
independent of right yeah right
Weinberg when he was giving his ideas
about anthropic see you string theory
yes look we need such a thing in order
to explain why cup much constant is zero
close to zero and he said there must be
a very large number of solutions string
theorists out there are great so that's
the starting point now then he went and
then a few years later the people
discovered dark energy on people's and
strings it said great you know we're
okay but we now have to explain exactly
why we have this actual value that we're
seeing and so people try to construct
solutions and then there's still debate
and that's part of what people in my
community including myself
raise recently have they constructed the
solutions that Weinberg wants or whether
more interestingly is the dark energy
changing in time and if this such is it
observable and can we measure it would
be as a prediction on string theory so
it'll be very very concrete predictions
of that idea of the landscape of string
theory so the idea that string theory or
landscaping exists who cares we cannot
measure it there's no a relevance for us
we're only in one of these universes not
so fast because if we find general
patterns of them for all of them and if
ours is one of them therefore we make
specific predictions about are yours how
did you cut them understanding that
understanding what probably the universe
has could be very specific one and we
can check it for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you